I
wonder what's going on in a place like
this?
Neo
nedo I managed to get the ship boouuuuuuuuuuuuuuuuuuuuuuuuuuuuuuuuuuuuuuuuuuuuuuuuuuuuuuuuuuuuuuuuuuuuuuuuuuuuuuuuuuuuuuuuuuuuuuuuuuuuuuuuuuuuuuuuuuuuuuuuuuuuuuuuuuuuuuuuuuuuuuuuuuuuuuuuuuuuuuuuuuuuuuuuuuuuuuuuuuuuuuuuuuuuuuuuuuuuuuuuuuuuuuuuuuuuuuuuuuuuuuuuuuuuuuuuuuuuuuuuuuuuuuuuuuuuuuuuuuuuuuuuuuuuuuuuuuuuuuuuuuuuuuuuuuuuuuuuuuuuuuuuuuuuuuuuuuuuuuuuuuuuuuuuuuuuuuuuuuuuuuuuuuuuuuuuuuuuuuuuuuuuuuuu neo nedo boat
Two people can't get on board Two people can't get on Minne-kun.
If my only wish is your smile
, I want to protect it
[Music]
When I wake up,
you'll surely be back in Urashima I'm having a
good dream
[Music]
Mori 5 years ago Excuse me
Ant  How did you carry such an amazing sentence to the beach?